[Music]
welcome to maine um
set in amongst the most gorgeous points
uh marshall point that lighthouse is
historic run forest run
[Music]
i was actually shot here i'm gonna do a
beautiful take
on a blt we're gonna make it a little
bit more modern i'm gonna elevate it
and it starts
here
on main street with their most amazing
lobsters that have literally been
plucked 50 meters
down on that beautiful shore there first
off i'm going to start literally
seasoning my bacon
and
i'm going to put
a little touch of butter on there this
is a seaweed butter that is locally
churned and it's flavored with
the truffle of the sea so
why fat on fat well it's going to get it
super crispy and
it's gonna make it really seriously
delicious
now
first off
bacon on
okay
now
let's grill them on there
let that
beautiful
butter melt
start getting that really nice
and crispy
beautiful
look at that
so beautiful turn that over
so good
now that seaweed butter it's going to
add more texture to that bacon and the
flavor it's going to give it that really
nice
sort of truffle
elegance
and that is beautiful once you've got
the color on there
get it really nice and crispy and then
just pull it to the side
and let them slowly crisp up and it
sounds crazy when i'm putting fat on fat
but
the flavor
of that incredible seaweed butter
is beautiful
from there
i'm going to start
my eggs
and i'm going to literally just lightly
fry an egg
also but just nicely done
melt the butter
tap the egg on a flat surface and then
crack that in there
and just gently
two eggs
let that butter froth up
lightly season
and it'll touch the smoked paprika of
those eggs into that butter that gives a
really nice rich flavor to those eggs
let that bubble up
and put them on there slowly to cook
now
look at this bacon
beautiful
so crisp
on
and now for the lobster
the lobster has been blanched
taken out the shell
down
down down and down so opens that up
again
keep it nice and open stops it from
curling up
my seaweed butter goes
into the pan
lightly delays that with a little touch
of olive oil stops the butter from
burning like i said it's a super rich
blt
but done with some magic
now
butter goes in
lobster goes in
[Applause]
beautiful
eggs cooking beautifully
lobsters me a quick saute
just nice and quick
so good
i'm going to grill the avocado
to grill that avocado go nice and soft
my onions
and leave them quite thick so i can
grill them beautifully just
run them through
and straight onto the grill
amazing
so
lightly brush the bread
with the olive
oil going to get it nice and crispy
i'm going to toast it both sides
lightly season that bread
both sides
and then onto the grill again
beautiful
now look at my lobster
look at the color of that
bacon nice and crispy
eggs fried off beautifully and look
at lobster
goes on
all the little knuckles coming out
i want to get that butter over there
you'll see why in a minute
now we start the magic okay
in here
got one
tablespoon of mayonnaise
a little zest
of lemon
from there
take a little bit of this seaweed okay
dry it and all i've done is pickle this
seaweed and then chop that up nice and
fine and that's going to go through the
mayonnaise that's going to give you a
little bit of acidity
and this seaweed is literally picked
from that shoreline down there
okay and into the mayonnaise
so think of the flavors that we're
building here
beautiful
now
look at that
ready to go one more
ingredient these beautiful tomatoes okay
and i'm gonna do now is just slice look
at that
beautifully done don't move them every
time you move them they break up so just
slice
and don't move them
look at that
the secret here
is to literally season them
there
a touch of olive oil over there
and now
we start get your avocado
scoop that out
the grilled avocado
and literally
smash that
over your bread
and that
is an amazing flavor
right there smashed avocado gives a real
nice density
to that lobster okay
from there
lift your tomatoes up
on
next
take your lobster okay slice it
lengthways
so you've got that nice crispy texture
and lay that across
so we're building up those layers now
we don't want to be stingy
with our lobster especially in maine
okay the claws slice in half
and pack in the edges really important
otherwise you'll be
cooled out
as a cheap mainer now from there once
all that lobster's cut
man lightly season it
then from there
take your beautiful mayonnaise and slice
that down
beautiful baby gem lettuce look at the
color of these
look at that
that is so beautiful
and then just break that in i want to
dress it inside that juice there
okay and you place that on there
snap
and dress all that flavor
onions on
and then
top that with my bacon
oh man
bacon
bacon
lift up
that beautiful egg
okay
juice as well and let that sit
on top
you sit that there
and you go on say goodbye i'll see my
mouth
and put that over there
you ready
because this is like a blt like never
before
because once you've eaten this
you run faster than forrest gump any day
now
you still want to put the yolks right so
i'm going to slice through them i'm
going to slice around them hold it down
nice and firm
let the knife do the work
push it down
open that up
come on
that one
is for you
and that one
is for me
and that is what you call a beautiful
main
stunning
blt
now run forest run
[Music]
you